Dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, Beleidigungen oder sogar Witzen. natürlich genauso wie... Und ihr müsst dann auch nicht immer hinten dran schneiden, hallo und herzlich willkommen zum Podcast-Ufer, das leisten wir dann schon selber. Dieser Podcast steht zu 30% Aus Begrüßung. Aus Begrüßung. Und wer wir sind. Ich bin stellte Notiz, dass Florentin Will wird gerade auch schon im Intro wahrscheinlich mal angekündigt. Und im Outro und im Banner steht es auch nochmal drüber und in der Einleitungstext steht es auch noch drüber. Ihr wisst, wer wir sind mittlerweile. Ja, und selbst wenn nicht, auch nicht so schlimm. Ihr dürft uns nicht die Anmoderation nehmen, das ist alles, was uns noch bleibt. Unsere besten Formate sind weggebrochen. Das ist unser Stroheim. Wir haben keine Antenne Afrika mehr, wir haben keine Antenne Auenland mehr. Ne, wurde uns alles weggestrikt, alles urheberrechtlich geschützt und deswegen alles, was wir noch haben, ist es ist mir eine große Ehre, ihn hier heute begrüßen zu dürfen. Er ist einer der Namen, auf den man immer wieder stösst, wenn man sich mit feiner Unterhaltung in Deutschland beschäftigen möchte. Ach so, ich habe das in den Schachmacher ziehenblättert. Ja, da können wir gleich nochmal drüber reden. Er ist die erste Google-Seite, wenn man Unterhaltung googelt. Er ist Stefan Dietze. Hallo. Hallo und herzlich willkommen auch von mir. Ich freue mich sehr, dass wir heute hier sind. zu meiner Seite, zu meiner Linken sitzt, wie immer. Er sitzt hier die meiste Zeit, auch wenn ich nicht hier bin, sitzt er dann trotzdem hier und überlegt sich über dem Schreibtisch gebeugt Gags für die Folge, fein erlesen. Er ist auf Seite drei, wenn man nach Unterhaltung googelt, aber auf Seite eins, wenn man nach Marte googelt, flotten will.
Hallo, vielen, vielen Dank. Und du sitzt hier wirklich auf deinem riesigen Luxussessel, wie so ein König sitzt du da.
Du thronst zwei Meter über mir, ich muss hier auf dem Boden kriechen vor dir, auf meinem kleinen Holzstuhl, aber ich finde das nicht schlecht.
Krösus, sagt man dann.
Krösus?
Krösus, wie King Krösus?
Ja.
Ist das eine reale Gestalt oder ist das so eine Märchenkisch? Ist das sowas wie Mammon? Ich weiß es auch nicht. Das schnöden Mammonswillen, das ist auch so. Wer sind diese... Und warum macht man nicht immer die mal so ein geiles Fantasy-Lower? Ja, Mammon und Krösus. Mammon und Krösus. Das war tatsächlich bei mir das Problem. Und die wecken die ganze Zeit schlafende Hunde.
Ja, ich bin ja ein Mensch, ich bin ja gefangen zwischen zwei Welten. Einerseits natürlich der Heerenhohn- und Akademikerwelt. Ich bin studierter Philosoph, ich lese dicke, dicke Bücher mit grossen, grossen Buchstaben.
Und grossen Bildern.
Und grossen Bildern. Und andererseits bin ich natürlich auch ein Popkulturknecht. Also ich bin unterwegs auf Tinder, TikTok, ich kenne mich aus, natürlich ich zocke Warcraft 3, ich bin natürlich mitten in der Unterhaltungskultur drin, was natürlich manchmal zu ulkigen Überschneidungen in dieser beiden Welten führt. Ja und du weißt auch, dass du Philosoph von beiden wahrscheinlich nicht so richtig angenommen wirst. Richtig. Beide Seiten hassen dich. Ja, ich fühle mich auch in beiden Welten nicht wirklich zu Hause. Und das war mir schmerzlich bewusst, als ich ja studiert habe in München Philosophie. Und es ist natürlich schwer, Anschluss zu finden an Philosophie-Studenten, weil die teilweise auch einfach in einer anderen Welt leben. Und dann versucht man natürlich zuerst das Semester, ist natürlich nicht ganz leicht, so Freunde finden oder halt irgendwie Leute, wo man sich so ein bisschen anschliessen kann. Und so ist dann ganz schwer, und dann ist man ganz froh, wenn man jemanden findet, neben dem man zufällig zweimal saß und halt sich irgendwie ein Radiergummi ausgeliehen hat, um irgendwie die Simpsons-Figuren wegzuradieren, die man auf die Klausel geschrieben hat. Und dann so nach der Vorlesung geht man dann so zusammen raus und dann meinte ich auch noch so mal, du, ah, sag mal, so, wie heisst du auf Facebook, dann können wir uns vielleicht so befreunden oder so. Face was? Und er meinte nur, Facebook ist für mich die Hure von Babylon. So, ich will einen Film sehen, wie King Kong gegen die Hure von Babylon kämpft. Das meine ich. Ich will gerne einfach diese ganzen Sprichwörter, weil darum geht es doch, moderne Filme sind auch IPs, die existieren, die Leute ins Kino bekommen. Ich will, dass die Hure von Babylon gegen Krösus auf dem Rücken eines Riesen-Mammons kämpft. Darum geht es mir doch nur. Und Justiz sagt die ganze Zeit, wer gewonnen hat einfach. Aber es ist stockblind, redet irgendwie mit der Wand und niemand weiß, womit sie redet. Aber ist es nicht so ... Wie muss man man sich eine Philosophiestudentin vorstellen? In meinem Kopf sind, ich habe da immer halt von Kant gehört, dass der ja schon eher jemand war, der auch gerne große Partys geschmissen hat, also immer so einen strengen Tagesablauf hatte, aber immer auch Drogen und Partys auch immer daran eingeplant hat. Nach striktem Plan hat er dann abends 18.00 die Gäste zu sich geholt,
dann gab es kurz Musik, dann gab es eine Vorspeise. Bier, viel Bier, ein legendärer Biertrinker.
Hat sehr viel getrunken, gesoffen
und nebenbei aber
wahrscheinlich auch einfach das Leben und die Menschen studiert.
Sind so Philosophie-Studenten,
also sind das outgoing Leute,
weil das passt nicht gerne zu meinem Kopf.
Nee, überhaupt nicht, eigentlich gar nicht,
aber ich habe jetzt auch nicht mit so wahnsinnig viel Kontakt gehabt, aber ... Ja, weil du halt aus der anderen Welt kommst, weil du Warcraft 3 gespielt hast. Ich glaube, du musst natürlich auch in dem Moment, in dem du Philosophie-Schulern bist und da durch diese heiligen Hallen wandelst in München, ist ja alles sehr beeindruckend an der LMU, da musst du natürlich auch so eine gewisse andere Person annehmen. Da kannst du jetzt nicht irgendwie, hey Leute, habt ihr gestern den Futurama gesehen, so da musst du natürlich auch ein bisschen vor dir selbst und vor den anderen auch eine Rolle spielen.
Da zieht man sich schon mal die Tunika an.
Ja, da sieht man die Robe an und den Lorbeerkranz und dann muss man natürlich da auch schreiten können.
Also du musst schreiten können, das ist klar.
Stolzieren?
Stolzieren, also Lustwandeln reicht da nicht mehr.
Flanieren.
Flanieren und auch wenn da irgendjemand beim Schlendern erwischt wird, der fliegt sofort raus.
Wer bummelt, fliegt.
Das war die erste Ansage, wer bummelt, fliegt. Das steht auch, das ist das, was auf Latein über dem Gebäude steht. Wer bummelt, fliegt. Und generell sehr... Quim bumulus, phlegronus. Generell sehr diskussionsfreudig auch und ich erinnere mich mit Hochgenuss an die Momente zurück, wo... Und hochrotem im Kopf und zu spät und Jacke falsch rum an,
ich in der dritten Reihe saß und dann
erstes Seminar, Kant oder so,
erstes Seminar, Professor fängt an
zu reden, erklärt so und dann meldet sich
ein Student und widerspricht Kant und sagt,
naja, das sehe ich aber anders.
Und dann wird der Professor mit so einem,
ja, jetzt hören Sie sich das erstmal vier Jahre lang
an, verstehen das und dann können
Sie vielleicht irgendwann in Ihrer Masterarbeit widersprechen. Aber jetzt hören Sie sich das erstmal an. War das so verstehen das und dann können Sie vielleicht irgendwann in Ihrer Masterarbeit widersprechen.
Aber jetzt hören Sie sich das erstmal an. War das so gesagt? Ja, das hat so gesagt im Grunde, im Sinne von so, ja, du hast keine Ahnung. Und dann gab es erstmal Bier, dann gab es erstmal Freibier für alle und dann wurde gesessen. Ganz viele Croutons auch, also so ganz große dicke Säcke mit Croutons, ich weiß auch nicht warum, das scheint so ein Philosophensnack zu sein, die übrig geblieben sind aus der Kantine, haben dann wirklich so kistenweise Croutons ganz merkwürdigerweise reingeworfen und die wurden dann so geschüttet über, also der Dozent hat die dann so geworfen wie Konfetti über die Studenten. Wird ja so Tauben füttern. Im Grunde, wir haben alle so den Kopf in den Nacken geworfen und haben versucht, ein bisschen was zu bekommen. Wir hatten ja alle grossen Hunger. Grossen Münder. Grossen Münder und grossen Hunger. Okay, also muss man sich das Philosophiestudium vorstellen. Vielen Dank dafür, für diesen kleinen Einblick. Ich stelle mir auch immer vor, in meinem Kopf, wenn jemand sagt, ich studiere meinetwegen Psychologie oder sowas, denke ich mir die ganze Zeit, bei mir ist immer so ein Klischee im Kopf sofort. Ich habe so eine sehr genaue Vorstellung von den einzelnen Studiengängen. Und bei Psychologie zum Beispiel denke ich mir die ganze Zeit, ihr alle also weil man lernt ja die ganze Zeit über Menschen und natürlich wendet man das an, dann ist man ja auch mit selektiver Wahrnehmung unterwegs und dann sagt die eine oh, jetzt habe ich mich heute wieder geärgert über den und den und man sagt, ja gut, mit so einem Vaterkomplex braucht man sich nicht wundern, dass sich das so triggert. Also ich denke mir die ganze Zeit, man traut sich ja selber, weil man ja selber wahrscheinlich die Leute so rumjudgt, weil man Psychologie studiert, traut man sich ja selber nichts mehr zu sagen, weil man die ganze Zeit Angst hat, da therapiert zu werden oder sowas. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Ich stelle mir bei, wenn jemand sagt, ich stelle mir die Psychologie, stelle ich mir mal vor, wie da so fünf Studenten an so einer Ecke stehen und so einen Geldschein an der Schnur haben und der Geldschein so liegt im Gang und dann kommt irgendwie so ein dummer VWL-Student
vorbei, so Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Steuern, Ausgaben, Derivate, Devisen und kommt da so vorbei, will nach dem Geldschein greifen und die Studenten ziehen ihn so weg und dann so hihihihi und dann schreien sie irgendwas auf in ihr Experiment
und dann haben sie den Menschen ein bisschen besser verstanden.
Ja, im Prinzip ist es so wie Pokémon, so hihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihihih und Kopf laufen rum und die VWLer und BWLer immer Geld, Geld, Geld, Gewinn, Maximum, Gewinn, Maximum. Ja, im Grunde schon. Eigentlich gibt es doch bestimmt auch so, wer ist der klügste Studiengang oder so eine Art Kampf, Arena-Kampf oder so, wo die so eingeliefert werden und dann so gegen einen Löwen und dann welcher Student bleibt übrig als letztes, gibt es bestimmt, oder? Alle kämpfen gegen einen Löwen. Wer würde am ehesten gegen Löwen gewinnen? Ich keine Ahnung. Welcher Studiengang würde am ehesten gegen Löwen gewinnen? Ich glaube schon eher so Geschichtswissenschaften, so die Florenzleute oder so, die sich ihr gesamtes Leben mit der Wirtschaft von Florenz im 15. Jahrhundert auseinandersetzen. Gut, weil die im Konkreten das Seminar hatten, wie man Löwen besiegt, muss man jetzt auch einfach mal. Ja, das stimmt. Das lernen nur wenige. Vielleicht Biologen, die dann einfach so den Balzruf kennen. Ich glaube Musik. Ja? Ja. Die bezirzen können mit einer schönen Lyra. Nee, weil die die hauen können mit der Gitarre. Mit einer schönen Harfe. Nun muss ich Instrument eher lernen nach den Selbstverteidigungsmaßstäben eigentlich. Deswegen finde ich auch cool, das ist eigentlich...
Oboe, du kannst so ein Oboe wie so ein Speer.
Aber das ist doch auch mal ein geiles Crossover, so Whiplash meets Power Rangers, so eine Jazzband, die gleichzeitig aber auch Bösewichte bekämpft. Also wenn jemand einen Auftritt hat und dann bricht plötzlich, keine Ahnung, ja gut, Tremolon oder irgendwie sowas, der Musikbösewicht.
Ich bin Tremolon!
Ich bin Triole, Triole, Triole.
So drei Köpfe, das ist so wie Fluffy.
Arpeggio, Arpeggio, oh nein, es ist Arpeggio, Arpeggio, Arpeggio, Arpeggio, Arpeggio, Arpeggio. Und dann plötzlich stehen alle Jazzmusiker auf und verwandeln ihre Instrumente in Waffen und kämpfen gegen die Bösewichte. Alles natürlich metaphorisch, auch auf eine gewisse Art. Ja, aber auch viel nicht, aber auch viel einfach Quatsch. Der Schlagzeug hat natürlich somit zu zwei seinen Stäben, aber am coolsten ist natürlich der, der dieses Sticks, das coolste ist natürlich der, wie heisst dieses Instrument, diese lange nervige Röhre? Ich glaube, wie heißt das? Und Karl Karlasja an der langen nervigen Röhre spielt jetzt Drrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschschsch Das hab ich auch schon in einer Partitur. Braucht man auch nicht. Es ist in Klammern, diese Linie ist immer in Klammern. Egal, was es ist, so als Notenschlüssel hast du immer damit, man weiss, welches Instrument es ist, hast du den Augenroll-Emoji. Der kann aber, glaube ich, auch gut kämpfen mit seinem Regenstab. Der kann dann so richtig wie so Donatello mit so einem Kampfstab kämpfen dann gegen die Feinde und macht dabei noch schöne, eher entspannende Klänge. Macht dabei Regengeräusche. Macht dabei Regengeräusche. Gut, man braucht ihn aber auch nicht für die Story.
Er hat keine spannende Arc.
Nee, das ist eine dieser Szenen, die man auch rausschneiden kann.
Wie bei, wie hieß dieser Film, der den Special Effects Oscar gewonnen hat?
Mit diesen Wasserwesen.
Pacific Rim?
Nee, nee, nee, nee, ganz, ganz, also.
Shape of Water?
Ui, es wird ja immer falsch, mein Herr.
Huuu, ey. Okay. Uiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiui Shave of Water? Es wird ja immer falsch, mein Herr. Huhu! Hey! Anscheinend lernt man in den Philosophiestudien, wie man das unsympathische Arschloch der Welt wird. Aber apropos Crossover. Apropos Crossover. Wir kriegen natürlich weiterhin tolle Geschichten von euch eingeschickt zum Thema Crossover. Kleines Feedback an meiner Stelle, gerne kürzer, gerne wirklich kurz knackig eindampfen. Floride liebt es kurz und knackig. Ich liebe es kurz und knackig, das ist ein guter Autor, muss er es auch können. Ich bin ja großer Fan von Stefan Zweig und er schreibt viel darüber, auch so wie er schreibt. Und dann meinte er einmal, dass er zu seiner Frau gegangen ist und meinte, heute war ein richtig guter Tag, heute habe ich drei Seiten weggekürzt. Ja. Wo man richtig sagt, das ist ein guter Tag. Ein guter Autorentag ist, wenn du es schaffst, drei Seiten rauszukürzen. Super. Das haben unsere Kurzgeschichten-Autoren noch nicht ganz geschafft, aber wir wollen mal weitermachen, und zwar ... Das kommt wieder eine der schlechtesten Geschichten, die aber dafür am kürzesten ist, richtig? So, ich sag mal wieder ... Beschreib mal deinen Kuratiervorgang. Mein Kuratiervorgang ist ... Nicht im Spamordner. Sortieren nach Größe, also nach Kilobyte-Größe und die Kleinsten kommen dran. Also hütet euch vor Bildern. Viele Leute posten Bilder und Gifs noch rein, macht das lieber nicht. Macht die Mail zu groß. Und zwar kommt die Geschichte von Yari. Und wie gesagt, ich sag dir wie immer nicht, welche Universen hier gemash-upped wurden. Ich versuch selber herauszufinden. Welche hier in das grosse Narrativ Waffeleisen gespannt wurden. So, Achtung. Ich lass mal offen, welche Universen es sind. Achtung, es geht los. Walter unterrichtet Chemie. Ja. Ja, ich hab's. Ich möchte lösen. Troy, Sportstar der Schule, versteht nichts und lässt. In der letzten Reihe sitzend lässt sich seinen Basketball auf dem Finger kreisen. Ja. In einem verzweifelten... So Troy. Bist du Troy? Jetzt schon so Troy. In einem verzweifelten finalen Versuch, seinen Schüler doch noch etwas über Redox-Reaktionen beizubringen, fängt Walter an zu singen. Zum Höhepunkt der Choreografie, kurz nach dem Cringy-Dad-Rap über Chemie, geht der Gesang in ein fürchterliches Husten über. Walter spuckt Blut und landet im Krankenhaus. Krebs? Krebsdiagnose.
Nur noch ein paar Monate zu leben.
Es folgt ein recht düsterer Filmabschnitt, in dem Walter verschiedene Schülerinnen und
Schüler anheuert, seinen Meth an der Schule zu verkaufen, Drive-It abhängig, verpasst
zwei wichtige Spiele und wird deshalb was für die Fliege abgeschmissen.
In einer emotionalen Szene, in der er von den Folgen seines Drogenkonsums singt, Songtitel
Crystal Killed My Spark, wird er von Walter beobachtet, der erkennt, was er angerichtet
hat.
Drive-It Drogenabhängig.
Ja.
Er ist ein, was wir angerichtet hat. Troy wird drogenabhängig. Es ist der grosse Wendepunkt im Film, Walter hört nach einer letzten grossen Nummer auf zu dealen, Troy wird clean und wieder im Team aufgenommen. In der letzten Szene das Finale der Meisterschaft gewinnt das Schulteam und alles endet in einer grossen musikalischen Nummer. Während der Choreografie erhält Walter einen Expressbrief, er hat gar keinen Krebs. Fehldiagnose. Ups! Das steht da drin. Ja, der Kurier wird spontan zum Teil der Choreografie und siehe da, auch Walter Junior ist plötzlich gesund, schmeisst seine Krücken fort und zeigt eine wilde Breakdance-Performance, die End. We're cooking math together, once you know, not too much, just a little bit.
Vielen Dank an Jari für dieses Cross-Off, vielleicht kannst du lösen, möchtest du lösen, welche Universen hier gemäschten wurden?
Ich glaube, das waren Highschool-Musical 1 und Breaking Bad.
Und Highschool-Musical 3. Die wurden hier in einer Wegen-Belanche. Naja, hier wurden gewisse Elemente aus Highschool-Musical 3 und so, aber vor allem die spannende Story da beim Teamspielen oder nicht aus Staffel Folge 1 wurden genommen, der beste Film. Hast du wiedererkannt? Habe ich wiedererkannt und Breaking Bad natürlich toll. Ich finde es super, mega gut. Ja, finde ich auch gut. Idee an der Stelle, Ice Age meets High School Musical, Ice School Musical. Nur wegen des Namens. Nur wegen des Namens auch und einfach ein tanzendes Mammut stelle ich mir auch für zuvor. Ich hasse, hasse, hasse, hasse Filme, die animierte Figuren und echte Live-Action-Figuren zusammenbraten. Okay, du hasst Spaceballs. Ich hasse Space Jam. Okay. Ich hasse Space Jam. Okay. Ja, warum? Es ist furchtbar. Es gehört nicht zusammen mit Albern. Roger Rabbit? Flabber? Flabber? Es wird nicht besser, wenn du das Geräusch machst. Ehrlich gesagt, nein, das gehört nicht zusammen. Das ist immer albern, auch Muppets, Muppets Show. Muppets? Was? Flabber, Muppets? Ja. Du magst kein Muppets! Aber Muppets, das sind ja Puppen. Das ist ja nicht animiert. Puppen, auch Yoda. Keine Puppen. Alf? Alf? Nee. Also jetzt wird es lächerlich. Doch, Puppen sind okay, yeah. Aber jetzt auch nicht so ganz oben da drauf. Okay, yeah? Okay, yeah. Aber alles andere mischt mir das nicht zusammen. Das gehört nicht zusammen. Das sind zwei getrennte Welten. Jetzt bist du wie der Purist gerade noch großer Mashup-Affaschionado. Affaschionado, Faschist und jetzt? Gerade weil ich noch großer Mashup, ja klar, Mashup-Faschist bin ich dabei, bin ich super. Ich wette ja genug gerade gegen deine Ice Age-Kackidee, aber High Street Musical ist ja wohl ein Live-Action-Film. Das heißt doch nicht, das muss ja keine animierten Mammut sein, das kann ja auch ein Elefant mit ein paar Teppichen drauf sein, das kannst du ja irgendwie special-Effektsmäßig umsetzen. Ja, das gefällt mir. Teppichen und so grossen Speeren drangeklebt. Ja, genau. Das ist auch kein Problem. Das kann man doch heute mit den Special-Effects umsetzen. Tiere sind so süss. Ja, manche. Ich gucke mir gerade mittlerweile so gern ab und zu so süße Tiervideos an. Der Reddit-Thread, oh, A-A-A-W, ist mittlerweile mein liebster Reddit-Thread. Das macht so Spaß, mein liebster Subreddit. Ich habe neulich ein Video gefunden, wie einem Affen Zeichensprache beigebracht wurde. Das war eine Gorilladame. Und der wurde seit ihrer Geburt quasi Zeichensprache beigebracht. Man konnte sie einfach fliessen, mit den Menschen auf Zeichensprache reden. Fantastisch. Und sie hat dann irgendwann den Wunsch geäußert, dass sie gerne ein Kätzchen hätte.
Weil die Pflegerin hat ihr immer aus einem Gute-Nacht-Buch vorgelesen, so eine Kindergeschichte mit Zeichensprache. Und die Affendame, die Gorillafrau, hat es halt einfach super geliebt, dieses eine Buch wollte sie immer wieder hören. Und da drin hat er ein Mädchen Kätzchen geschenkt bekommen.
Und dann wollte diese Gorilla-Frau... Super geliebt, dieses eine Buch wollte sie immer wieder hören. Und da drin hat sie ein Mädchen Kätzchen geschenkt bekommen.
Und dann wollte diese Gorilla-Frau seitdem immer ein Kätzchen geschenkt bekommen.
Dann haben die dann ein Kätzchen gegeben und sie durfte den Namen wählen.
Die Gorilla-Frau durfte den Namen wählen und sie hat sich entschieden, sofort für den Namen All Ball. Weil die Katze für sie aussieht wie halt ein Ball. All Ball. Als wäre alles Ball. Und dann ist diese süße Erzählerstimme, die die ganze Zeit sagt, und dann hat die Gorilladame Susi sich für den Namen All Ball entschieden. Und dann wird die ganze Zeit über All Ball. All Ball. Fantastisch, fand ich super. Abererell ist All einfach eine tolle Silbe, auch wenn du Anwalt bist, einfach All Law. It's All Law. Einfach schon. Blablabla. Ja, aber hat die dann auch nicht mal kritische Sachen geäußert, so, ja nett, danke für die Katze, aber warum bin ich hieresperrt? Oder es war die freie Fliege. Das kam jetzt in dieser süsten Doku im Reddit-Thread Oh, nicht zu tragen. Das wird dann ausgeschnitten. Aber dann habe ich ein anderes Video gesehen, wo ein männlicher Gorilla Zeichensprache beigebracht bekommt, und der war deutlich einsilbiger, also der war eher halt so der wollte kein Kätzchen haben, der hat aber immer von dem Tod seiner Mutter gesprochen, die von Wilderen erschossen wurde. Und jemand hat davon erzählt, der sich daran erinnert, dass er quasi ein Kindheitstrauma mit sich herumträgt, weil er den Tod seiner Mutter quasi miterlebt hat, wie sie erschossen wurde. Und das hat er dann sehr grafisch dargestellt. Und dann kann man ja auch nicht, man kann ja dann nicht weghören, man muss die Augen zumachen. Wenn man in Zeichensprache plötzlich etwas gesagt wird, was man nicht hören will, muss man einfach ganz, wobei es ist einfacher, als die Ohren zuzumachen. Ja, das stimmt schon. Der dann sehr grafisch von dem Tod erzählt. Aber krass, dass sie sich daran erinnern. Ich habe Google das massiv unterschätzt, offichtlich. Das ist nicht eine geile Idee, so ein Podcast von Affen. Du nimmst zwei Affen. Nee, das ist schlecht. Aber können die sich dann untereinander auch mit Zeichensprache unterhalten? Klar. Ja, das ist ja geil. Dann setzt du zwei Affen nebeneinander, mit so einer Scheibe dazwischen, dass die sich nicht hören. Ach so, ich dachte wegen Corona. Nee, dass die sich mit Zeichensprache unterhalten müssen. Und dann brauchst du nur noch so zwei Praktis, die halt dann das transkribieren, was die als Zeichensprache sagen. Und einsprechen. Und einsprechen. Mega! Und dann lassen wir das von Oliver Kalkofe und Guido Kanz einsprechen. Ja, und das ist der perfekte Podcast und der heißt All Ape. All Ball. Der heißt All Affen, All Ape. All Ape. Kannst du den direkt in mehreren Sprachen veröffentlichen? Das finde ich fantastisch. Wir reden, aber das ist eine gute Idee mit der Scheibe dazwischen, weil wahrscheinlich, wie unterhalten sich denn Affen? Weil ich glaube nämlich, dass sie, wenn man denen Sprache beibringt, eine Zeichensprache, die hat ja mehr Vokabeln wahrscheinlich als eine Affengrunzen. Naja, das kann man so leicht nicht vergleichen. Doch, ich glaube, das kann man gar nicht vergleichen. Was du kommunizieren willst, glaube ich so. Ich glaube, wenn man denen eine Zeichensprache zur Verfügung stellt, ist das das beste Instrument, für die sich auszudrücken. Ja. Das glaube ich, auch untereinander. Ohne Zeichensprache könnte der Affe gar nicht von seiner toten Mutter erzählen, einem anderen Affen. Ja. Weil er das gar nicht, aber naja. Ja, ich glaube nicht. Affen haben ja keine Sprache. Setze ich das denn durch zur Zeichensprache dann irgendwann? Weiß ich nicht, aber diesen Podcast will ich mir anhören. Da bräuchst du nur so einen Moderator, der halt dann so ein paar Themen reinreicht, so hey ... Nee, ehrlich gesagt, nein. Ich bin Purist. Ich will einfach nur hören, worüber Affen sprechen. Ich brauche keine Begrüßung, ich brauche keine Verschiedung, ich will hart rein, ich will mitten im Wort rein und einfach mal hören, wo wir die jetzt gerade sprechen. Die müssen ja, vielleicht wissen die auch gar nicht, dass sie einen Podcast haben. Ich hoffe, dass sie es nicht wissen. Sie wissen es nicht und es ist super privat. Da bin ich zugegangen und habe gefragt, ob sie mit mir gehen will, aber sie hat einfach gesagt, die habe ich immer ignoriert. Was? Was will der Mann da drüben mit dem Mikrofon? Ich will mich nicht mehr mit dir unterhalten. Ich komme hier leider nicht raus. Hör auf, mit mir zu reden, hör auf, mich anzuschreien. Du hebst die Hände zu hoch in die Luft, das ist unhöflich. Ich glaube, es ist ein sehr, sehr darker, grafischer Podcast. Ja, aber ich würde ihn mal anhören. Beide über die Tode ihrer Eltern sprechen, weil Wilderer die abgemurkst haben. Was, wenn es der grauen nach dem Podcast der Welt ist? Der dann vielleicht so sagt, ja, jetzt aber mal abseits der schrecklichen, meine Eltern sind gestorbenen Geschichte. Der mal so ein Nüsschen reinreicht, damit die auf andere Gedanken kommen. Oder so Zettel reinreicht, so ein Redakteur einfach so Themenangebote. Ich würde es mir anhören, lieber Zo, falls du zuhörst, melde dich bei uns. Wir haben
die Ressourcen.
An wen sprichst du gerade?
Wir haben die Ressourcen,
das umzusetzen. Wir leben nicht in der
Blümchenwelt, wo es ein Zoo gibt.
Falls ihr die Ressourcen habt,
meldet euch auf jeden Fall. Wir können
Praktikanten
rekrutieren.
Wir haben Thais an der langen Strippe.
Wir haben Thais, die könnte auf jeden Fall Zeichensprache transkribieren. Thais hat jetzt einen Freund. Thais hat jetzt einen Freund. Okay. Woher weißt du das? Weil wir ihn noch bei Instagram folgen. Ach so. Und da hat sie es öffentlich gemacht. Ich glaube, es ist okay, wenn man das sagt. Ist öffentlich. Ja, ist doch perfekt. Dann können die beiden einfach direkt schön ihre Flitterwochen oder keine Ahnung, was Jugendliche heutzutage machen, können direkt ihre Flitterwochen verbringen, damit zwei Affen zu transkribieren.
Das ist doch romantisch.
Das ist ja romantisch.
Stimmt, Valentinstag. Wie hast du den Valentinstag verbracht?
Stefan hat seine linke Hand zu einem O geformt, seine rechte zu einem Zeigefinger und dann sehr, sehr wild, ja, intensiven animalischen Geschlechtsverkehr simuliert. Und dabei seine beiden Augenbrauen weit hochgerissen und mir direkt in die Augen gestarrt und sich auf die Lippen gewissen. Nö, ganz ruhig. Schön nochmal Tenet angeguckt, nochmal schön die alte Flipchart rausgeholt. Tenet rückwärts angeguckt. Ja, warum nicht? Into the Spider-Verse, guter Film. Habe ich letzte Woche Primer empfohlen? Äh, ja. Das gilt fast für jede Woche. Du empfiehlst jede Woche Primer. Ich möchte doch mal Primer empfehlen. Nur damit es hängen bleibt, empfehle ich es gerne zweimal. Es gibt mittlerweile auch so einen Twitter-Account, der die Empfehlungen immer noch mal kuratiert. Vielen, vielen Dank, Pufo Empfehlungen, glaube ich, heißt das auf Twitter. Ja, kann der bitte explizit Primer noch mal erwähnen? Jeder zweite Post ist Primer, immer und immer wieder. Und die Leute beschweren sich schon, sagt, Floridin empfiehlt die gesammelten Werke von Hegel und Stefan hat wieder Primer empfohlen. Und die Leute kommentieren, hä, das habt ihr doch schon gepostet. Nee, nee, er hat es noch mal empfohlen. Primer wurde tatsächlich noch mal empfohlen. Ja, Primer wurde jetzt noch mal empfohlen. Es ist immer dasselbe tatsächlich. Aber ja, für einen Zeitreisefilm natürlich auch Clever, Meta. So kennt man Stefan, immer einen Schritt voraus. Clever und Meta. Clever und Meta. So nennt man mich. Stefan Metatize. Ja. Zwei Metatize, aber Meta mit A. Immer ein Meta-Vorsprung. Die PR-Abteilung ist da auch irgendwie mehrmals falsch abgebogen, das hat einfach nicht mehr funktioniert. Also, ich dachte jedenfalls, wahnsinnig interessant, ich habe Gorillas immer unterschätzt, ich dachte, dass die das nicht können, Zeichensprache lernen, richtig als Sprache, und ich fände es total interessant, Tieren dieses Mittel zu geben, weil, wie cool, wie ein Blick in eine andere Welt, das ist ja wie mit Außerirdischen zu sprechen. Ja, ist total cool, aber muss man das denn wirklich auf Gorillas beschränken? Also zum Beispiel, klar, dann sagst du, alle sagen immer, Delfine sind so schlau, aber ja, das ist einfach nur eine Behauptung, so ja, von mir aus. Aber ich glaube, so etwas, worauf ich richtig Bock hätte, wäre so etwas wie Ameisen, dass du irgendeine Möglichkeit findest, mit Ameisen zu kommunizieren, weil das ist ja dann, geht ja über das Individuum hinaus, das ist ja dann so, wenn die dann so Buchstaben formen können mit Ameisen, das wäre richtig.
Nee, weil ich glaube, Ameisen an sich, also die Ameisen, diese mobilen Ameisen, die sind glaube ich einfach lame. Die sind einfach, die sind ja null intelligent auch, die kann ja nicht sagen, die laufen, laufen, laufen, laufen, essen, essen, essen, essen, essen, essen, essen, essen, laufen, hinterher, hinterher, hinterher, riechen, riechen, riechen. Das sind, glaube ich, Ameisen. Oh, meine gesamte Familie ist tot, wurde von dem Zwölfjährigen mit einer Lupe zerstört. Essen, essen, essen, laufen, laufen, laufen. Lupe, Lupe, Lupe, Sonnenstrand, Sonnenstrand, tot. Au, au, au, au, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot ich lame as fuck, aber die Ameisenkönigin, die ist glaube ich einfach so die eloquenteste, perfideste, ich glaube es ist super gruselig. Podcast Ameisenkönigin meets Bienenkönigin und dann wirklich Let's Go, einfach Let's Go, einfach so die zwei Herrscherinnen der Tierwelt. Ich glaube, damit züchtet man so eine Superrasse, weil, holy fuck, das ist so gruselig. Ich glaube, man züchtet so eine Superspezies, weil die beide tauschen sich halt aus, wie perfide sie ihr Volk unterjochen können. Wie gut ist das denn am Anfang so von Fahre und dann kommen die Ameisenkönigin und die Bienenkönigin und dann Zeichensprache. Ich stelle mir vor, ich komme nicht mit, ich komme nicht mit, mit ihren Flügeln, die sind zu schnell und Thais transkribiert so schnell sie kann. Ich stell mir vor wie Harry Potter 4, wie alle haben so verschiedene Wege, da hinzukommen. Also an dem Treffpunkt haben die so krasse Aufschritte wahrscheinlich, das Bienenvolk und das Ameisenvolk. So Flickflacks und so Breakdance und so. Die Bienen machen dann so eine Schwarmformation, wo sie dann irgendwie so Sachen in den Himmel schreiben, wie so Jets. Diese Jets, die drüberfliegen. Ja, die so Streifen der lassen. Ja, dann so Honigpollen fallen lassen. Das ist so gelbe, gelbe so Striche am Himmel. Und dann landen diese mächtige Bienenkönige. Dabei die Fanfaren. Und die Ameisenkönigin kommt so super grazil, wird abgestellt. Können die nicht auch fliegen? Stimmt, die können fliegen. Auch fliegen, glaube ich. Weiß ich nicht, keine Ahnung. Die haben bestimmt einen geilen Auftritt. Aber das, Alter, guck mal, das ist die Podcast-Revolution, auf die wir gewartet haben. Ganz im Ernst. Ameisenkönigin und Ameisenkönigin und dann einfach so, so, ja, Gossip. Einfach so Gossip, einfach so die ganze Zeit so Gossip. Glaubst du, die sind beide so sassy? Ich glaube, die sind mega sassy. Einfach so, oh, schon wieder das gleiche Kleid an. So sehe ich aus, schwarz und gelb. Oder verwöhnt. Ich glaube, sie sind verwöhnt, weil die kriegen ja alles hinterhergekragen. Schwarz-gelb ist so 2017. Glaubst du, die bischen sich so an? Ja, ich glaube schon. Du bist braun, du bist komplett braun. Ich bin komplett braun. Onesie. Aber das stelle ich mir gut vor, aber auch für den Sprecher. Das könnte man eigentlich auch als Prank machen. So Guido Kanz kommt ins Tonstudio. Okay, was soll ich einsprechen? Hallo Guido, schön, dass du da bist. Du, wir haben hier einen Dialog, da haben wir eine Bienenkönigin und eine Ameisenkönigin gegenübergesetzt. Das wurde dann transkribiert von einer Praktikante namens Thais, die hat die Zeigensprache interpretiert und das wurde dann in den Text umgewandelt. Das müsstest du lesen, du liest die Bienenkönigin.
Okay.
Nee, Barbara Schöneberger und Anker Heckel lesen Bienenkönigin versus Ameisenkönigin.
Wie gut ist das denn?
Aber die sind auch zusammen im Tonstudio.
Die brauchen so eine richtige Chemie eigentlich.
Ey, die sollen uns auch ein bisschen interpretieren und spielen halt.
Das finde ich schon gut.
Und dann brauchst du noch jemanden, der die ganze Zeit zzzzzz macht. Oder Barbara Schöneberger muss die ganze Zeit bzzzzz machen. Auch bzzz machen. Aber ganz im Ernst, ich stelle mir das, ich glaube, das ist das Gruseligste, was man hören kann als Mensch. Ja. So eine Ameisenkönigin Zeichen beibringen und ein Mikro hinhalten und das dann transkribieren. Ich glaube, das ist das Gruseligste der Welt. Ohne Scheiße, was haben die denn für Themen?
Ja, das ist ja die Frage.
Weil dann geht es ja nur um Überleben, Töten, Expansion.
Wenn du mal so einen gut laufenden Bienenstock hast,
dann geht es eben gerade nicht mehr ums Überleben.
Dann hast du das ja gesichert.
Meinst du, dann geht es auch um Work-Life-Balance?
Dann geht es um Work-Fly-Balance.
Glaubst du?
Dann geht es auch irgendwie, ja, jetzt ist die Flugstrasse gesperrt oder irgendwie das Wetter ist schlecht oder da gibt es, ich glaube, die haben halt... Der Bienenstock soll schöner werden, der Bienenstock soll schöner werden. Wow, wie viele Leute die Referenz verstehen, wie viele Leute diese Referenz verstehen. Aber ich glaube, die beraten sich dann, wie sie dieses achtjährige Kind unter Kontrolle kriegen, dass einfach jeden Tag drei Bienen tot stampft. Und was können sie dagegen unternehmen? Und dann verbünden sich die Ameisen und die Bienen gegen dieses achtjährige Kind und bringen zu Fall. Bring es um. Bring es um, ja. True Crime. Leute lieben True Crime. Und dann kommen die Biber und müssen den Fall aufklären, die auch alle Zeichensprache können. Was glaubst du, sind die lustigsten Tiere, um jetzt mal so einen Comedy-Podcast an den Start zu bringen? Ja, ich glaube Schnecken. Ich glaube Schnecken, die haben eine Menge, ich sehe immer, wenn die so unterwegs sind, so ganz entspannt, also die kichern immer so und dann fließen sie wieder weiter. Fließen. Ich glaube, die haben eine gute Beobachtungsgabe. Ich glaube, brauen die auch. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Die sind so langsam und dadurch haben die, glaube ich, so einen sehr entspannten Blick, so einen Jerry Seinfeld, Larry David-artigen Blick auf die Welt. Vielleicht könnten die auch viel schneller sein, aber die wollen halt einfach, die brauchen viel Material, einfach die brauchen viel Content für ihr Material und gucken sich einfach oben und dann sagen, Tannenzapfen, oder? Auch verrückt. Fallen einfach runter dann irgendwann. Fallen runter und dann... Na, da muss man doch mal ran, glaube ich. Und dann ganz langsam weiter. Aber das ist doch auch... Vielleicht wollen die auch einfach nicht zu dem Stand-Up-Gick kommen, weil die nichts haben. Und deswegen... Ich bin jetzt hier noch auf der Acht, hier ist gerade die Hölle los. Die Hölle los. Nee, eben nicht mehr. Ihr kennt uns ja, wir sind Schnecken, wir brauchen... Wir kommen acht Jahre verspätet. Das stimmt, wenn sich das mal etabliert hat und die eine Schnecke, die sich mal richtig eilig hat, den kriegt er Ärger, weil sie schnell war. Aber das ist doch eigentlich auch ein Format, oder? Stand-Up der Tiere? Tier-Stand-Up finde ich auch gut. Tier-Stand-Up ist auch richtig gut. Weil wenn du jetzt, wir könnten ja quasi der Gorilladame sagen, dass jetzt mal sich ein paar Gags drauf schaffen soll. Stimmt, Humor müsste bei, oh ja. Aber angenommen, wir sagen, man bringt eine Horde Gorillas, bringt man bei Zeichensprache. Sondern dann sagt man, so, nächste Woche Dienstag, gut, dann müssen wir die Wochen vorbeibringen. Ja. Da haben die dann auch drauf. Dann sagt man, nächste Woche Dienstag ist ein Talentwettbewerb. Jeder zeigt von euch, was ihr am coolsten könnt. Was glaubst du, würden die machen? Und würde einer sich für Stand-Up-Comedy entscheiden und dann sagen so, also ich glaube, wie bei jeder Talentschau hast du 40% Tänzer, 40% Sänger, uninteressant. Interessant sind die restlichen 20%, davon natürlich nochmal 15% Jongleure, von denen wiederum 80% Diabolo, und ich glaube, dann hast du auf jeden Fall noch jemanden, der an dem Ast schwingt, so eine Rec-Performance oder so, einer im Reifen und dann natürlich Stand-Up und natürlich ein Poetry-Slam. Ich glaube, Ball, einer hat so einen Ball, den er hoch fängt und so oder sich drauf stellt und so was. Vielleicht so hoch und dann hinter dem Rücken fangen oder so was. Ja, genau. Das ist das Kunststück. Das fände ich gut, aber glaubst du, einer entscheidet sich einfach mal, und das hat die Wissenschaftler dann ganz schön beeindruckt, einer hat sich tatsächlich für Comedy entschieden. Einer hat sich für Comedy entschieden. Und der sagt, ich mach Comedy nächste Woche Dienstag. Und hat einen der Wärter gerostet und das fanden die Affen toll. Der Wärter nicht. Also der Wärter überhaupt nicht, der war stocksauer, aber die Affen haben wirklich sich kaputt gelacht. Lachen die dann in Zeichensprache oder lachen die dann lautlos? Applaus ist ja so, wenn man die offene Hand so hin und her wehlt.
Stell dir mal vor, die ganzen Arten.
Aber ich weiss nicht, ob es Lachen gibt.
Ich glaube, Lachen.
Nehmen wir doch so einen ergreifenden, nachdem wir der eine melancholische Affe, der dann reenacted, wie seine Eltern gestorben sind.
Oh Gott, schon wieder Egon.
Und danach macht der Performance alle Affen beide Hände hoch und dann wird geklatscht. Wo ist da die Grenze? Ich glaube nicht, ich glaube, wir können uns das abschminken mit der Ameisenkönigin. Warum? Weil die das nicht beibringen können, die sind auch zu dumm. Die tanzen doch eher, Bienen tanzen doch. Ja, die sind zu dumm, wir haben gar keine Ebene mit denen. Wir haben keine Ebene. Die müssen ja nicht klug sein, Thais muss klug sein. Die muss verstehen, was die sagen. Und dann muss sie es transkribieren. Die muss genau wissen, wenn die Biene so wackelt und so tanzt, dann heißt es das und das. Ja, gut. Also, weil ich glaube nicht, dass das funktioniert, weil wir haben keine Ebene mit denen. Mit Affen teilen wir 97 Prozent der DNA. Noch keine Ebene. Was? Noch keine Ebene. Noch ist ein tiefer Keil zwischen Mensch und Biene. Manchmal glaubst du, du hast recht, nur weil du Dinge spannend betont. Ehrlich gesagt macht das dein Argument nicht besser. Bislang! Okay. Aber ich glaube, dass diese Kluft zwischen Mensch und Insekt langfristig überwunden werden kann, wenn man einfach solche Austauschprojekte oder mal so einen Austausch. Ich glaube, das ist so gruselig, was Tiere denken. Ich glaube, das ist so crazy. Ich habe wirklich Regenzerhofer, wenn ich darüber nachdenke, dass so eine Ameisenkönigin, weil die haben es ja auch nicht schön da bei sich. Das ist wie so eine Gruft, wie so Kerker-Systeme und die bringen ja auch dann Tiere um, die nicht richtig arbeiten und sowas. Aber in dem Moment, in dem du Tiere Kommunikation beigebracht hast, kannst du natürlich auch ganz spannende Talkformate etablieren, zum Beispiel Talkformat Konfrontation. Da kommt dann mal so eine Bienenkönigung und so ein Bär. Und dann, ja, lieber Bär, die Bienenkönigin sagt, du hast vor letzter Woche schön deren Honig gestohlen, der war weg. Was sagen Sie denn dazu?
Ja, ich dachte, das wäre quasi so ein Agreement, so ein Handschlagdeal quasi, dass zwischen Bären und Bienen ein jahrhundertelanger Pakt besteht, wo ich dann einmal die Woche, meistens würde ich dann den Dienstagmorgen nehmen, in ihren Bienenstock lange, um mir eine gewisse Menge Honig zu besorgen. Gut, dann haben wir jetzt Ihre Position gehört, dann gehen wir nochmal das Wort an die Bienenkündigung hier. Wer schlichtet eigentlich, wer ist der Richter, der Biber? Der Biber, ja. Ja, erstmal danke für das Statement hier von dem Bern, vielen Dank, dass Sie sich bereit erklärt haben, hier anwesend zu sein. Es würde mich natürlich nur interessieren, was Sie denn denken, was Ihr Teil dieser Vereinbarung ist. Also Sie kriegen den Honig, Sie pranken da rein jeden Dienstagmorgen, das haben Sie also da auch schon zugegeben. Sie pranken da schon rein. Langen, Langen hatte ich gesagt. Ja, ich glaube, sie hat, na, aber da können wir noch mal ihre Hände.
Protokoll?
Protokoll? Der Achtarmige. Der Specht, der hat schon gesagt, Langen. Na gut, dann möchte ich da auch fair sein. Sie langen da jeden Dienstag rein. Was ist denn Ihrer Meinung nach die Gegenleistung, die Sie dem Bienenstock damit bieten? Na, ich würde sagen, dass ich langfristig gesprochen jetzt den Wald freihalte von anderen Fressfeinden. Fressfeinde ist ein Begriff, den wir so eigentlich nicht mehr verwenden möchten. Das möchte ich hier kurz einhaken. Aber wenn Sie es schon mal angesprochen haben, wen konkret meinen Sie denn mit Fressfeinden? Na, ich als Bär bin natürlich eine imposante Gestalt. Und ich nehme halt lange einmal in der Woche in den Bienenstock. Aber ich bin ja den Rest der Woche in der Gegend. Ich bin zugegen. Und dadurch verschrecke ich kleinere Tiere. Welche Tiere meinen Sie denn? Die vielleicht Interesse hätten. Welche Tiere meinen Sie denn? Ja, das weiß ich nicht, ob ich das jetzt ausführen möchte. Ich will jetzt ja auch keinen losstellen, aber ich sage mal so, so ein kleiner Dachs, ein Honigdachs, der hat natürlich auch mehr Interesse. Gut, dann haben wir hier eine Meldung aus dem Publikum. Ah ja, da meldet sich ein Honigdachs. Verleumdung! Verleumdung! Verleumdung! Verleumdung! Ich bin nicht der Honig, ich bin nur Essen. Ja, Sie haben es gehört aus dem Publikum, da schreit jemand, erbost Verleumdung, Herr Bär. Wie gehen Sie damit um? Ja, deswegen wollte ich jetzt hier niemanden outcallen, aber ich sag mal so, da gibt es halt andere Leute, die anders mit dem Honigstock umgehen. Gut, halten wir das mal kurz mal an. Wir haben noch eine Meldung aus dem Publikum.
Ah, ein Gorilla meldet sich da zu Wort.
Ja, also ich war vor drei Jahren in der Steppe unterwegs
und mit meiner Mutter, sie hatte mir damals,
sie zeigt mir eigentlich alles, was ich weiß,
hat sie mir damals beigebracht.
Und dann plötzlich kam so ein großes, knatterndes Gefährt angefahren. Wir dachten erst, da ist vielleicht jemand vom Weg abgekommen. Natürlich sind wir da sofort hingegangen. Dankeschön, dankeschön. Da ist kein Platz jetzt leider hier. Dann hat er sein. Da ist noch eine andere Wortmeldung von einem anderen Gorilla. Ja, ist es an? Ja, also kennt ihr das? Da sitzt ihr den ganzen Tag in eurem grossen Reifen. Und genau in dem Moment, wo es euch so richtig gut geht und ihr einschlaft, kommt der Menschenwerter vorbei und bringt euch die Schale voll Nussnüsse. Und das Publikum tobt und schlackert mit Pfoten, Pranken und Klauen.
Und der Vorhang schliesst sich. Haha, das ist lustig. Und Guido kann es moderiert ab. Das war's für diese Woche von Animal Talk, von All Animal. Bis nächste Woche, mach's gut, ciao. Guck mal, wir haben schon so viele tolle Ideen. Hat nicht jemand auf Twitter gepostet, dass es, ich glaube, ProSieben oder so hat jetzt gesagt, Leute, uns gehen die Ideen aus. Habt ihr welche? Das war, glaube ich, nicht der Tweet. Nee, ich glaube, ungefähr so war es. Wir haben wirklich, wir schießen aus leeren Kanonen, nee, irgendwie sowas, uns geht der Saft aus? Was haben Sie geschrieben? Kann man auch sagen, finde ich okay. Uns geht der Saft aus, wir haben kaum noch Druck auf der Folie. Leute, wir sagen, wie es ist, wir haben keine Ahnung, wir haben keinen Druck mehr auf dem Kessel. Wir haben keinen Dampf mehr im Kessel. Ich glaube, ihr versteht, was das Problem ist. Habt ihr vielleicht noch ein bisschen Zucker übrig oder so, können wir uns ein bisschen was für euch leihen. Hashtag Dampf hat mich auch irritiert. ProSieben. Aber vielleicht können wir da mal Formate einreichen. Noch besser, besser, wenn ihr die für uns einreicht und wir quasi, um nicht zu sagen, keine Arbeit haben. Genau, das wäre nicht ideal. Ich glaube, vielleicht gibt es auf der Puffopedia auch schon eine Seite Showideen. Ja, Hashtag Dampf, könnt ihr mal gucken. Hashtag Dampf könnt ihr einfach direkt verlinken. Das ist wie so eine große Schüssel beim Arzt in Rezeption. Greift da einfach rein, ProSieben. Also greift da einfach rein, wir haben so viele Showideen. Die meisten würde kostenlos haben. Steckt euch, viele Leute denken, da darf man sich nur eins nehmen. Nein, die Regel gibt es nicht. Jede Showidee kostet 50 Euro. Okay, oh, das ist ein Deal. Aber wenn ihr zehn nehmt, dann nur 400. Ja, also ab dann ist ein Rabatt. Da kriegt ihr einen Rabatt, da könnt ihr euch richtig die Taschenchen voll machen. Ist ja nicht so, dass wir da irgendwie Geld mitverdienen wollen, wir wollen ja primär sehen, diese Idee. Wir wollen die sehen, wir wollen vor allem auch Guido Kanz mehr sehen. Ich habe eine Nachricht bekommen, die fand ich sehr interessant, da hat sich nämlich jemand deiner Geschichte angenommen, deiner Revenge-Storyline letzte Woche, wo du einen Kollegen im Schachclub hattest damals,, der dann erfolgreich geworden ist. Richtig. Und quasi, da bist du ausgetreten, weil der dann bei Wetten, das war, mit seiner Kinderwetter erfolgreich war. Kinderwetter bei Wetten, das? Viele Leute konnten sich an die Wette erinnern. Wirklich? Und bei Twitter haben sie geschrieben, und einer hat, der Sven hat eine spannende Beobachtung geschrieben, jemand im Schachclub war im Fernsehen und Florentin nicht. Florentin hat daraufhin den Schachclub verlassen, eine Moderatoren-Ausbildung gemacht und sich in eine Show geschummelt, um mehrfach im TV aufzutreten. Wenn das keine Revenge-Story ist, weiß ich auch nicht mehr. Und ehrlich gesagt, da ist schon was dran. Du hast davon letzte Woche erzählt, da schwingt natürlich mit, dass ein gewisses Trauma entsteht. Du hast sofort gesagt, nee, ich will da nichts mehr mit dem Schachclub zu tun haben hier. Das hat dich alles zu sehr daran erinnert. Vielleicht ist es eine Art Trauma und du hast jetzt mittlerweile, verfolgst du einfach nur seinen Traum. Ja, das kann schon sein. Das ist erschütternd, wenn man plötzlich merkt, dass sein ganzes Leben eigentlich nur in diesem einen Nachmittag in dieser stickigen Bude beim Schachkutz bestimmt wurde. Es ist erschreckend, aber kann sein. Erschreckend und erregend. Ja, das ist ein bisschen schwitzig, aber also falls ihr, falls du zuhörst, lieber Schachwetten, Schachmeister, melde dich gerne mal.
Vielleicht gibt es da eine Versöhnung, vielleicht gibt es da einen Kompromiss, vielleicht können sich Erzfeinde mal wieder die Hand reichen, um diesen Bann zu lösen.
Hast du Erzfeinde? Ich glaube, du hast mal von einem erzählt.
Ja, ich glaube, also sowas.
Wollen wir die mal einladen? Ich würde gerne mal eine Folge mit deinem Erzfeind machen. Und du kannst eine Folge mit meinem Erzfeind machen. Ach so, okay. Oder unsere Erzfeinde machen zusammen eine Folge. Und Thais transkribiert das Ganze. Die können sprechen. Eingelesen von Jennifer Lawrence. Falls wir die kriegen. Und Brie Larson und Jennifer Lawrence lesen unsere Erzfeinde ein. Das kriegen wir hin, das kriegen wir wirklich hin. Ihr müsst einfach nur mehr Merch kaufen, dann können wir uns auch Jennifer Lawrence leisten, die diese Sache dann einliest. Gut, dann müssen wir unseren Erzfeinden nur erstmal Sachensprache beibringen. Gut, das ist natürlich viel Abwand, ja, das stimmt schon, aber ich, ja, also in meiner Schulzeit würde ich schon, was heißt Erzfeind, Erzfeind klingt immer so nach Hass, aber Konkurrent würde ich sagen. Weil ich würde immer noch, ich finde, dieses Format hat immer noch Potenzial. Beispiel die Erzfeind-Folge, Beispiel die Mütter-Folge, ich bin immer noch lustig, wenn unsere Mütter miteinander sprechen, finde ich auch noch super. Aber dann eine ganze Folge oder so als Segment? Nee, so eine ganze Folge, wie ich rede, 60 Minuten lang reden unsere Mütter miteinander. Oder halt unsere Eltern oder nur Mütter oder wirklich unsere Eltern. Wir wollten ja auch mal eine Folge nackt machen. Ja. Vielleicht kann man das kombinieren. Unsere Erzfeinde nackt oder so und unsere Eltern. Wir mit unseren Erzfeinden machen nackt, nee nackt eine Folge auch. Genau, wir sind nackt, aber die Erzfeinde nicht. Und wir kündigen das nicht an. Wir kündigen das nicht an. Und dann einfach die normale Folge. Es sprudelt, merkst du, wie das raussprudelt das uns? Jetzt geht's erst richtig los eigentlich. Wir haben richtig Dampf auf dem Kessel. Bei uns sprudeln Ideen raus. Dieser Podcast, ihr denkt, der ist schon tot gut geglaubt gewesen. Das stimmt. In Folge 160 ist schon, da kommt keine Folge mehr, das war's. Nein, das wird, das brudelt im Inneren hier. Ja, jetzt geht es erst richtig los. Ohne Scheiße, jetzt kommen erst richtig, jetzt die 300er, das werden die krassen Folgen, das werden die Folgen, da will ich grimme Preise für haben. Ja, aber du meinst, du hast auch einen Erzfeind oder hattest einen Erzfeind? Ja, ab und zu, also immer wieder Erzfeinde. Meistens halt in dem Genre, wo ich dann gerade versucht habe, Fuss zu fassen oder war, hatte man immer Erzfeinde.
Aber konntest du insgesamt eher den Sieg davon tragen oder bist du unterlegen?
Sieg. Sieg? Schon Sieg.
Auf ganzer Spur. Gerade ist Fabian Kranemann ein Erzfeind im Schach.
Deine Vergangenheit ist eigentlich eine blutige Schneise durch Erzfeinde, ein nach dem anderen.
Aber jetzt erzähl mal ganz kurz, ich muss es ja auch ansprechen, du hast dich natürlich verändert in der letzten Woche. Also ich komme hier rein, du trägst nur noch schwarz-weiss karierte Hosen, du hast einen grossen goldenen Anhänger mit einem goldenen Springer dran, du bist ja jetzt so ein bisschen zum Schachkönig geworden in der letzten Woche, du hast ja legendäre Schach-Grossmeister überzeugt von deinem Talent.
Wie hat sich dein Leben verändert?
Also wie ist es denn auf dem Zenit der Schachwelt
zu leben?
Leider
Okay.
Eigentlich können wir das Interview hier abbrechen.
Also ich dachte, es ändert sich alles in meinem Leben.
Deswegen das Outfit.
Aber ganz ehrlich, ich trage es nur noch, weil es sehr teuer war und weil es sich nicht lohnen würde, es nicht zu tragen, wenn es zu Hause verstaubt. Aber es hat sich nicht so viel geändert sonst, weil ich werde weder auf der Strasse erkannt, weil Turns Out das Jazz-Magazin Jazz liest niemand. und sonst werde ich auch nicht wirklich also nicht so dass ich jetzt eine Meldung war ja
dass ausgerechnet bei uns in Deutschland Zwei Zin, Jazz liest niemand. Und sonst werde ich auch nicht wirklich ...
Also es ist nicht so, dass es jetzt eine Meldung war,
dass ausgerechnet bei uns in Deutschland
der begeisterten Schachspieler der Geschichte ...
Nee, ist ein bisschen untergegangen in der letzten Woche.
Es war viel los in den Nachrichten.
Es war viel los, ich habe mich auch ein bisschen geärgert, viel los.
Auch so Trump-Impeachment-Krieg zum Ende und so.
Ja, kam ein bisschen ungünstig.
Also das war alles so, weiss ich nicht,
also da hätte man sich dann auch mal irgendwie, klar muss man sich da,, verstehe ich ja auch als Medien-Outlet irgendwie fokussieren. Ja. Aber ... Aber wie siehst du dich selber? Also, du bist ja natürlich einer der begabtesten Spiele der Geschichte. Wie geht man selber mit sich um? Wie schaust du in den Spiegel? Das würde mich interessieren. Ähm, ich schaue in den Spiegel und ich sehe meine ganzen ... Ich sehe meine Schachkette, ich sehe meinen Schachhut und denk mir ... Du siehst sein What would Stefan Tietze do Tattoo. Nee, ich denk mir vor allem, sollte ich das jetzt weiter, soll ich das in Angriff nehmen richtig und aus der Begabung was machen oder nicht, das denk ich mir. Das ist ja oft die Gefahr, dass Leute zu früh gehypt werden und dann so ein bisschen unter dem Druck zusammenbrechen. Aber ganz ehrlich, ich bin noch, jetzt mal ganz ehrlich, ich habe danach gespielt wieder, erst habe ich mich lange nicht getraut zu spielen, dann habe ich wieder gespielt und ich habe alles verloren, also so doll verloren. Deswegen glaube ich, es hat mich zerstört, das Lob, weil ich habe so eine Erwartung an mich, obwohl Jess24 rieche ich so auf und sack die ganze Zeit, so als ob die auch gar nicht wissen, wer ich bin. Wie können sie nur? In beider Hinsicht, in zweiter Hinsicht schade. Wenn sie wüssten, wer ich bin, würden die anders spielen, dann würden die nicht mit ihren Anfängertricks um die Ecke kommen und mich sofort besiegen, sondern dann würden sie sich ein bisschen zusammenreißen, ehrfürchtiger spielen. Mit dem Schau mal da und dann deinen König woanders hinziehen? Ja, nervig. Da fällst du drauf rein. Fäll ich drauf rein, aber so würden sie ja nicht spielen, wenn sie wüssten, dass ich der begnadetste Schachtspieler der Geschichte bin. So, Punkt eins und Punkt zwei ist, sie haben ja auch nichts davon, sie gewinnen gegen mich, freuen sich aber nicht angemessen. Stimmt. Die gewinnen gegen jemanden, der eine Elo von tausend hat, so die denken ja, gut. Man müsste da eigentlich mal anrufen und sagen, wissen sie überhaupt, gegen wen sie hier gerade gewonnen haben. Wissen sie gerade, was passiert ist? Ja. Und dann so, no? Sind ja oft Spanier das eigentlich. Ja, ja, ja. No? No gracias? Nein, es ist Stefano Tizioso, el grande Mastro. Die Magazine de Chess. Magazine de Rösselsprung, si. Si, claro. Ja, und das kommt viel zusammen. Ich muss mich jetzt wieder einschließen, ich muss wieder irgendwas damit machen. Ja, du hast zu sehr die Früchte geerntet, aber nicht gesät diese Woche. Du hast zu sehr gefeiert, du hast die Früchte ausgepresst, aber du hast nicht eingekauft, du hast nichts in Regal gelegt. Nee, ich habe schon noch sehr viel geübt, aber ich merke einfach, das hat mich jetzt gewohnt gemacht. Ich glaube, das war keine gute gesucherte Sache, das mitzubekommen, das Lob. Also das war die Schäffern-Titze-Schachphase, er ist einmal kurz, er hat es probiert, er wurde der beste Spiel der Welt und hat es dann mehr oder weniger wieder liegen lassen, das versandet. Jetzt ist Schlagzeug. Aber ich kann mich noch erinnern, du hast gesagt, du willst dir ein E-Schlagzeug kaufen und in dem Moment, in dem du gesagt hast, ich habe es mir bestellt, hat dir ein Kollege gesagt, ja, aber da gibt es doch jetzt diese ganz billigen Stöcke, die das komplette Schlagzeug ersetzen, weil die den Widerstand simulieren. Da brauchst du nur noch die Stöcke und du mit so einem Fehlkaufgesicht dann so in die Kamera geguckt hast. Nee, ein Riesenschlagzeug zu Hause stehen, das ist mega, sieht super cool aus. Moment, aber ein echter Schlagzeug oder so ein E-Schlagzeug? Es ist basically ein echter Schlagzeug, hat aber die E-Mesh-Heads-Fälle. Ist also nicht laut. Hat es komplett aus wie ein richtiges Schlagzeug. Das heißt, du kannst auch spielen, ohne dass ihr Nachbarn komplett den Verstand vernehmen. Die rasten immer noch komplett aus, weil, stellt sich raus, auch ein E-Drum-Set ist unglaublich laut. Oh nein. Doch, aber ist okay. Weil unter mir ist so eine Gewerbe, die sind abends nicht da oder wochenende nicht da, da wird getrommelt, bis das Zeug hält.
Aber Schlagzeuge sind auch wahnsinnig laut. Ich kann mich nur erinnern, ich habe ganz wenige Erinnerungen aus meiner Kindergartenzeit, aber eine sehr bildhafte Erinnerung ist, dass der Vater von einem guten Kumpel von mir mal in den Kindergarten gekommen ist und der war Musiker und Schlagzeuger und der hat da in der Turnhalle Schlagzeug gespielt für die Kinder und alle Kinder, hey, jetzt da ist der Vater vom Dingsar und jetzt spielt der und das war so laut, dass alle Kinder angefangen haben zu weinen, alle Kinder sich die Ohren zugehalten und haben angefangen zu weinen, weil es so laut war, dieses Schlagzeug und der Vater dachte so, ich bin hier der Coolste hier, ich werde den Kindern mal zeigen und der Sohn so, oh Papa, bist da, cool, guck mal, wie toll mein Papa ist. Und wirklich, also wie so eine Schallwelle einfach, die einmal durch die Halle ging, die Kinder umgehauen hat, alle geweint, es war so laut, so laut und mich alle geweint und irgendwann musste wirklich so eine Erzieherin eingreifen und sagen so, ja, danke schön, die musste hingehen und dem einfach den Hals umdrehen. Der musste den einfach komplett mit der Handkante einfach mal schön auf den Hals schlagen. Mit der Haute, auf dem Kehlkopf. Da gab die Hand, dem war schön so bewusstlos. Papa, Papa! Das ist immer ein Disney-Film. Das wäre mein Anfang für einen Disney-Film. Ja, ja. Aber wer jetzt die Hauptfigur, ach so, der Junge ist dann die Hauptfigur und der wird dann Pizzabäcker auch, oder was? Ja, klar. Okay, ja. Wie gesagt, ich glaube, Disney hat auch bald keine Kerzen mehr auf dem Kuchen, die brauchen glaube ich auch noch mal ein bisschen Hilfe. Das war der ProSieben-Tweet. Wir haben keine Kerzen mehr auf dem Kuchen. Da haben wir es doch. Aber also, wie hoch sind deine Ambitionen? Beim Schlagzeug jetzt. Weil kannst du den Schlagzeug überhaupt vernünftig alleine spielen? Oder ist es nicht sehr repetitiv? Ich habe keine Ahnung, ich möchte da nichts ... Doch, du kannst mit Bluetooth Spotify auf deine Kopfhörer streamen und dazu halt Schlagzeug spielen. Und gibt es dann so spezielle Songs, wo das Schlagzeug dann nicht drin ist, dass du dann so Karaoke-mäßig... Das gibt es auch, die gibt es auch, aber musst du ja nicht machen. Du kannst einfach über einen Song trommeln, das macht ja genauso viel Spaß. Aber es gibt dann schon unterschiedliche Komplexitätsstufen. Bei manchen Songs, nehme ich mal an, ist es einfach nur immer derselbe Rhythmus über das gesamte Song, aber manchen dann vielleicht auch mit Solo. Ja, bei vielen coolen Songs, da hast du tatsächlich sehr viele Abwechslungen, mal einen Riff hier, mal einen Phil-in da, mal einen Beckenschlag da. Okay, und ich gehe aber jetzt mal so, also ich kenne dich jetzt auch schon so eine Weile und wage mich an der Prophezeiung, du bist einfach full Whiplash gegangen, komplett also Hände blutig gespielt, Hände in Eiswasser getaucht. Ich hätte die Masterclass von J.K. Simmons gemacht. Ja, okay. Richtig, auf Ausgab hast du sofort mit deiner Freundin Schluss gemacht, hast gesagt, Eltern, ich will euch nicht mehr sehen, ich konzentriere mich jetzt nur noch auf Schlagzeugen, ich will ins Schäfer Conservatory aufgenommen werden. Und dann hat auch tatsächlich ein Professor vom Schäfer gesagt, wow, dafür, dass du erst zwei Monate spielst, bist du der begnadetste Schlagzeuger der Geschichte. Ja. Und dann habe ich mich ein bisschen aufgeregt, weil es nicht die Betrachtung bekommen hat, wie du dich mir gewünscht hast, im Ideal. Genau, dann warst du im Autounfall und hast es aber trotzdem noch geschafft zur Aufführung. Ja. Ja. Und jetzt habe ich überlegt, Tennis. Ah ja, okay. Cool. Ja. Ist doch nett. Warum nicht? Ich ehrlich gesagt gesagt, es gibt ja Leute auch, mit denen ich diese Schachfaszination geteilt habe, mit denen ich gespielt habe ab und zu. Und die tun mir auch alle wahnsinnig leid in dieser Geschichte. Ihr lässt du einfach zurück. Na klar. Aber es gibt ja viele Menschen, die haben so ein bisschen das Problem, die finden nicht so richtig ihre Leidenschaft, die finden nicht ihren richtigen Ort und ich persönlich mache Benjamin Blümchen verantwortlich. Viele Kinder wachsen auf mit Benjamin Blümchen, der einfach jede Woche sagt, fuck it, ich werde Feuerwehrmann, ich werde Arzt, ich bin Ritter. Ich habe bei mir auch überlegt, es ist nicht so gekommen. Entschalt dich fucking Benjamin, du bist ein fucking Elefant, das ist die fucking schlimmste Midlife-Price aller Zeiten, leg dich mal fest auf den Job, du kannst nicht den Rest deines Lebens Berufseinsteiger sein. Fucking Elefant. Nein, aber tut mir leid, aber der ist jetzt auch nicht mehr der Jüngste. Der kann nicht sein ganzes Leben Generationen Praktikum machen und immer sagen, ich will jetzt hier Indianer werden, dann bin ich Pirat, dann bin ich Ritter, jetzt bin ich Bergbau. Nein, leg dich mal fucking fest. Was war die langweiligste Idee, die Benjamin jemels hatte? Ich glaube, Mathematiker. Ich studiere Soziologie nochmal. Geht nochmal in die Sinologie rein, einfach. Ja. Wir müssen gleich nochmal kurz über die Millenniumprobleme sprechen. Ja, gerne, auf jeden Fall. Du hast da wahrscheinlich Durchbruch gemacht. Das machen wir gleich nochmal. Aber ich mache auch tatsächlich dafür die Sitcoms verantwortlich. Auch so Seinfeld und sow was, weil im Prinzip lebe ich ein Sitcom-Leben.
Ich habe meine Folgen, pro Woche habe ich so Problem of the week, ich habe ein neues Hobby, etwas Neues gefunden und dann passieren aber so extreme Sachen. Aber auch nicht, das ist so eins zu eins mässig, so Sitcom
on the nose mässig. Es sind keine
komplexen Storylines, es ist
der Weltmeister sagt, du bist so genau
als Mensch im Scha, alles ist so ein bisschen so karikiert. Ja, und vor allem Sitcom hat ja auch die Struktur, so dass am Ende der Folge eigentlich war schon alles so gut, wie es war. Ja, oder alles bricht zusammen und wird dann so wieder genau zu dem, was es vorher war. Ja, so Full House, Stephanie will in der Schule beliebt sein, fängt an zu rauchen, was heißt es
cool zu sein, wie soll muss ich mich verstellen?
Am Ende der Folge ruft meine Freundin halt doch wieder an und frage,
ob es wäre gut, dass sie rumkommen.
Ja genau, und am Ende sagt Danny dann, Danny Ocean
sagt dann, du warst doch toll,
wie du warst, du musst dich nicht verstellen, um anderen zu
gefallen, du warst doch eigentlich toll.
Zack, nächste Folge. Also immer so,
man probiert was aus und dann heißt es, nee, du warst
schon ganz okay. Ja. Was ist das für eine Botschaft? Flabber! Aber ganz kurz, ich hätte unter der Woche eine Podcast-Idee, nämlich wir lösen ein Millennium-Problem. Millennium-Problem sind die grossen ausgestrebene Mathe-Probleme, die extrem schwer zu lösen sind. Es gibt noch ungelöste Mathe-Rätsel. Ich glaube, es sind alle ungelöst, außer zwei oder drei oder so. Aber ich glaube, man kriegt eine Million Dollar, wenn man ein Millennium-Problem löst. Und ich glaube, wir sind die Richtigen, das zu tun. Eine Million Dollar. Eine Million Dollar? Und wahrscheinlich eine Fields-Medaille. Eine was? Eine Fields-Medaille ist so der Nobelpreis der Mathematik. Aber wenn jetzt in einem Jahr mehrere Leute Millennium-Probleme lösen würden, dann wird es schwierig. Man muss sich die teilen. Dann muss man sich die vielleicht teilen. Ich dachte jedenfalls, wir gehen da hin. Erste Folge ist erstmal, wir suchen uns erstmal das Problem aus, was am lösbarsten erscheint. Also du sagst, der Podcast geht so lange, bis wir das Problem gelöst haben. Der Podcast ist nur Recherche. Ich sage, der Podcast sind, ich würde sagen, realistischerweise würde man sagen, der Podcast geht so lange, bis wir das Problem verstanden haben. Ich glaube, wir brauchen alleine 40 Folgen, um das Meleneproblem überhaupt zu verstehen. Wir müssten wahrscheinlich erstmal Mathe studieren, um es überhaupt zu verstehen, geschweige denn es zu lösen. Aber ja, wir können es gerne ausprobieren und dann halt abschweifen und eher uns überlegen, was wir mit einer Million Dollar tun würden. Und gucken und dann regeln, wir googeln, was kostet ein Hubschrauber? Was kostet ein kleiner Hubschrauber? Folge eins, wir gucken, was wir bekommen würden fürs Preisgeld. Ja, genau. Folge zwei, wir recherchieren rum, was sind die Probleme, die es noch gibt. Ja. So, und dann geht es aber schon los. Folge drei, Ghostwriter. Wir brauchen Mathematiker, die uns helfen. Wir rufen bei Mathematikiker an. Ja. Habt ihr Lust, uns unterstützen bei unserem Projekt? Ja. Aber im Prinzip ist die ganze Staffel eins erstmal nur, wir versuchen, ein Problem zu verstehen. Ja. Und haben uns quasi erstmal ein Problem auszuwählen, was am lösbarsten erscheint, und das zu verstehen. Ja, ich würde gerne die Riemann-Hypothese angehen, aber die ist natürlich schon knackig, würde ich sagen, also Schwierigkeitsgrad schwer. Kannst du das kurz erklären? Nee, aber ich glaube, nee, wirklich nicht. Folge vier, wir erklären das Problem. Ja, es hat was mit Primzahlen zu tun und ob es eine Funktion gibt, die die Primzahlen abbildet, so und das ist schon schwierig, aber da, das glaube ich, ist schon mal schwierig und natürlich auch die Frage, die im Raum steht, angenommen, wir schaffen es, kriegt jeder 500.000 oder kriegt einer vielleicht mehr als der andere? Oder wenn der eine jetzt die zündende Idee hatte, wie ist es? Oder sagt man, man investiert zusammen, man kauft sich was zusammen, einen Heißluftballon zum Beispiel, den wir beide nutzen dürfen. Also ich am Werktage zum Beispiel, du am Wochenende den Heißluftballon oder wir kaufen uns einen Hubschrauber, den dann der eine jede gerade Stunde fliegen darf und der andere jede Stunde. Also das sind halt Dinge, die müsste man sich überlegen. Und dann würden wir erstmal Excel-Tabellen anlegen und Berechnungen durchführen, inwiefern es Sinn macht, den Helikopter neu zu kaufen oder nicht, weil der fehlt dir auch schon an Wert. Wenn du den kaufst, verliert er schon an Wert, weil er dann gebraucht ist. Und wie viel Treibstoff verbraucht der Helikopter? Nicht, dass wir jetzt sagen, wir kaufen für eine Million Dollar den Helikopter und können uns seinen Treibstoff nicht mehr leisten. Ich weiß nicht, was für ein Helikopter, ob man den an der Tankstelle diesel oder so. Ich wollte jetzt mal, ich wollte wirklich eine Ex-Tabelle, eine Gleichung aufstellen, weil folgendes Problem. Ich habe mir jetzt, mein altes Handy war kaputt. So, Bildschirm gesprungen und ich fand es eh kacke.
Jetzt habe ich mir ein neues Handy gekauft.
So, jetzt kriege ich das für das alte, kriegt man ja immer noch Geld.
Man kann das ja immer noch einschicken, entweder beim Hersteller selber oder aber du kannst es bei verkaufen, bei Ebay-Kleinanzeigen oder was auch immer.
So, jetzt habe ich noch eine Versicherung auf dem alten Handy gehabt.
Die kannst du nicht mitnehmen.
Jetzt ist das alte noch nicht so alt, das heißt generell kriege ich noch sehr viel Geld für das Handy. Jetzt habe ich dann das neue gekauft, um dann ein neues Handy zu haben. Das alte schicke ich jetzt ein, benutze die Versicherung, um den Bildschirm zu reparieren, damit ich es jetzt wieder quasi fast als neues Handy weiterverkaufen kann. Jetzt ist die Frage aber, macht es Sinn, immer ein Handy bis zum Ende, ich frage nur aus ökonomischer Sicht, nicht ökologischer Sicht. Nee, das ist ja generell egal. Das ist völliger Unsinn, in der Gleichung gerade. Macht es Sinn, das Handy bis zum Ende aufzubrauchen? Klein m für Moral wird rausgekürzt. m rausgekgekürzt macht es sinn das handy komplett bis zum ende zu benutzen oder macht es sinn dass weil es irgendwann hinten raus also verliert das neue handy schneller den wert als das alte handy das glaube ich meine frage ja oder wann wann macht es sinn neues handy sich zu kaufen weil jetzt kriege ich jetzt plötzlich habe ich sehr wenig Geld fürs neue Handy ausgegeben, weil das alte noch so viel wert war.
Ja, ich weiß es nicht, ich kenne mich damit nicht aus, ich habe seit Jahren ein altes Handy, das auch schon kaputt ist, wo sämtliche Glasscheiben kaputt sind, aber kannst du nicht auch das aufschrauben oder selber das Kobalt rauskratzen oder so und das dann auf dem Schwarzmarkt verkaufen, ist das nicht der beste Preis? Ich weiss es ehrlich gesagt nicht. Ich kenne nur ein guter Freunder Freund von mir ist in Kupfer eingestiegen und holt jetzt überall Kupfer raus. Und er sagt immer, wenn ihr irgendwie alte Kabel wegschmeißt, schickt die mir, ich hol das Kupfer raus. Und wir haben ihm auch schon so eine Maschine geschenkt, wo man aus Kabel das Kupfer rausholen kann. Und der hat tonnenweise Kupfer bei sich zu Hause, so viel ist das ja nicht wert, aber der holt das überall raus, irgendwie so ein Kilo, sechs Euro,
glaube ich, oder so, also da musst du schon echt ordentlich wegkupfern, damit
da was hängen bleibt. Da muss aber
umgekupfert werden, da musst du dich
dull und dusselig kupfern.
Ja, und das fand ich eigentlich auch
spannend, dass da, du kannst ja dann irgendwie
dann auch dein Smartphone so
wiederverwenden. Hat der rote Haare?
Nein. Würde mir passen.
Ja.
Dann wird das Hit kommen.
In meinem Leben würde ich jemanden treffen,
der Kupfer kauft und verkauft,
der rote Haare hätte.
Weil irgendwie das...
Ja, ich verstehe schon, ich verstehe, worauf du hinaus willst.
Das Package würde stimmen. Ja, aber die Welt ist
nicht so oberflächlich, wie du sie gerne hast. Bei mir ein bisschen doch.
Die Welt ist keine Sitcom, Stefan Tietze.
Und damit entlassen wir auch euch wieder eure Welt.
Das Leben ist keine Sitcom.
Ihr habt echte Probleme, die müsst ihr wirklich angehen.
Ja, das Leben ist keine Sitcom, aber es gibt trotzdem ein Happy End.
Hm.
Also.
Meine Erfahrung noch nicht.
Nee?
Gut.
Ciao!
Weheben ab! Ciao! Wehem ab!
Wehem awkward ab!
Bleiben kurz am Baum hängen!
Ups! Könnt ihr kurz mit dem Besen?
Entschuldigung!
Könnt ihr kurz mit dem Besen leider hängen?
Wir sind in dem Baum hängen gewesen.
Sorry, wir können es nicht, können ihr kurz...
Ja!
Danke!
So, wo ist der Blasch? Könnt ihr kurz, ja, tuk, tuk, tuk, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablab